gigantische monster spinne terrorisiert
haus zwei männer aus der dominikanischen
republik entdecken die gewaltige
tarantel an ihrem hauseingang
das tier ist fast so groß wie ein
menschlicher kopf bedrohlich klettert
sie nach oben einer der männer schnappt
sich einen holzstock schlägt die spinne
zu boden doch noch ist sie nicht außer
gefecht auf dem boden liegend haut er
weiter auf sie ein schlägt sie in die
flucht bis die tarantel irgendwann
verschwunden ist und die männer dann
endlich aufatmen können
trotzdem die feine art war das von den
freunden nicht denn die spinne hat
vermutlich nur unterschlupf gesucht
[Musik]